welcome then
to couples counseling
it's nice to see of all of you here
that late in the conference i know it's
a really difficult kill to
be honest to yourself to go to therapy
but i heard that you and your deep
learning code you had some trust issues
and today we are going to work on that
and see how we can resolve them
but jokes aside today will be about use
writing reusable tests for your deep
learning code quick questions who knows
about unit tests
who knows about integration tests
who cares about the difference
okay then that is not the right talk for
you um no um i this talk won't be making
any difference between integration test
unit tests it's all just testing if i
say unit testing army testing
so
keep that in mind
why am i interested in
deep learning unit tests this is really
simple
i'm a part-time phd student and
some time ago
i
wrote some code for a project of mine
and the results were
extremely good should have been
suspicious at this point
but anyway
i wrote the paper and when i was nearly
finished i had a last look into the code
and there was a bug
and
the results without this bug were pretty
[ __ ]
so
i fell into a deep deep hole i know it's
called deep learning but not that way
yeah and when i climbed out again i
thought okay this will never happen to
me again and then i had a look in how to
write unit tests for my deep learning
stuff
and this is why i'm here today
so
uh tldr
this talk is about that you stop doing
this
this is a code snippet that appeared a
lot of times in my modules where i
defined my network architecture because
i wrote down some python code and then i
wanted to see okay does it work
um
okay i just
call the file directly and uh execute
this code at the bottom of the script
and see if it works nice
afterwards
i deleted this again because i didn't
want some random code to clutter my
my module
obviously then i changed something on
the module and then i wrote it down
again
and then i deleted it again
and i did this for an embarrassingly
long time
and what i want you to do
is start doing this instead
this is an example of
a unit test with the unit test package
which is built in in python
and it does exactly the same thing as
the code snippet before but in a more
sustainable way
okay
[Music]
today i will show you how to write tests
like these
i will be using the unit test package
there are other packages out there most
notably pi test
um this should not be an endorsement for
the unit test package but it's the one
that is built in and i thought it's
the most easy to use no additional
dependencies you can just get started if
you have python installed
we will
use this on a little
project
as an example
the project directory looks like this
and what this is this is a variation
auto encoder
that will be trained on the ms data set
and it is implemented pythorg what you
can see here we have a data directory we
have a source directory with all your
code we have a test directory which is
currently empty
we have a readme where we have the
requirements
and the first question uh we should ask
now is
what should we test
and the answer is everything in the
source folder obviously yeah maybe not
the run script but because this is
really boring it doesn't do anything
just calling trainer punk fit
but everything else we should test
probably
and in this talk we will go over the
different um
aspects of our code the data set the
model the trainer
and see which kind of tests we can
implement for these aspects
and we will learn on the way what is
important about writing unit tests for
deep learning
after each section we will have some
concluding thoughts
um
just as a reminder what we have learned
so far
okay
let's get started first of all
what are good tests good tests are first
of all fast because you will be running
them a lot and if they're slow you will
skip them and that's not good you will
run these tests a million times during
development and if they run longer than
even a second you will just not use them
second
these tests should be independent
which means
it should not matter if you run a single
test if you run all of the tests or the
order of the tests each of these should
be completely independent from each
other
and the last one is your test should be
readable i consider tests to be part of
the
documentation of your code
and if your documentation is not
readable you can just skip it
so these are the three
things we should keep in mind when we're
looking at our tests and
we will start with the data set
so i saw already that there are
there were talks about data testing we
are a step further we assume that our
data is okay and we are concerned about
the process of loading the data from
disk and getting it right at the gate of
our model
and the most obvious thing we should
test is
if the data that we get out of our
data set has the right shape
so
what we see here is a simple
test function
which first instantiates our data set
this is a really simple
class that just wraps the torch vision
amnest data set and provides the
training and the test split as
attributes and what we do here is we
simply pull the first sample out of our
training data set and see if it has a
bright shape
that's it
nothing more
and
so this is really simple because it's
the first example
you can see here that we're testing for
32 by 32 pixels which is because
inside the data set we're applying a
padding so that we get to a power of
three in terms of
size of the
image okay we only have to test one
sample here
because we already know that our data
set has only images that are of the same
size so
keep in mind
don't do superfluous stuff test only the
things that you know you have to test so
if every image is the same size you only
have to see if one image has the size
you're expecting
second
we have to scale the data because what
we get here
is a urine image between 0 and 255.
and we have to convert this our outer
encoder expects the images to be pixel
values to be between minus one and plus
one
and
to test this we have to go over the
whole data set because there could be
a fluke sample
which is corrupted or i don't know
and we have to find this sample this is
why here a single sample is not enough
we have to go over the whole data set if
your data set is too big maybe you want
to sample it a bit
but in this case we can go over the
whole data set because it's
tiny
okay what we're just doing is
for each sample we're checking if the
max and the min are inside of our
boundaries and what we're checking too
is
that there are samples that are greater
or
lower than 0 because a common error that
we could do is just scaling our data
between 0 and 1 or i don't know between
-1 and 0 and to check for this we have
the second two asserts in there
okay
the next part is a little bit more
complicated
we want to use data augmentation for our
training
and data augmentation
[Music]
means in this case we have random
augmentations so if i pull the same
sample two times from the data set
it should be different
but only on the training data we don't
want to augment our test data so the
most important thing we are testing here
is
does our
augmentation return random deviations of
our samples and if it's activated on the
training set and if it's activated on
the test set
deactivated on the test set so we have
two functions here which do basically
the same thing to check if the two uh if
i take two samples uh uh assemble two
times if they are different
um and the first one just checks if they
are all different and the second one for
the test that checks if they are all the
same and as you can see here
this is pretty redundant and third rule
of tests comes in it should be readable
and redundancy is probably not that
readable
so we can just extract a helper function
here which we will call check
augmentation
and this one just
is just here to see
to do exactly the same stuff but you can
check if it's if the augmentation is
either active or if it's not active and
with this helper function
we can then just uh merge our two test
function into one and just uh check both
of our splits
when this test fails
we will not know where it fails because
as you can see here we merged two tests
to different aspects we want the tests
into one function
um
but if the first one fails the second
one will not run and then we fix the
first one and then we run it again the
second one will fail we don't want to do
that we want to
we want this function to run both tests
and then only tell us which of them
failed to do that we can use the subtest
context manager for
[Music]
for this so here we just grab our calls
in the subtest context manager so that
they will both run even though one fails
and then
the test runner will just tell us that
test augmentation in the subtest
train
failed
the important thing here is to remember
you should
test both of your splits because or
at least think about are the differences
in behavior from my data set for the
training set the test set or the
validation set
and you should always test both
okay
and
here comes last thing about
in the data set which is if it plays
nicely with the pytorch data loader you
may think this is not an issue i mean
it's a data set
how much can go wrong
a lot
because one time for example i wrapped
the
function that read the data from the
disk into a cache because i was reading
a lot of data frames and i didn't want
the same data frame to be read again
if i had two consecutive calls to the
same data frame so just lru cache
which worked nicely on
doing it in the same process but when i
wanted to use multiple workers it
crashed because the lru cache
cannot be transferred to another worker
i didn't know that and it failed in
production
because i only tested it locally with a
single worker or no no workers at all so
the lesson learned here is just check if
your data set is able to
be used by the data loader
and
especially
test if
it can be used in multiprocessing
for this to do this
we just use subtests again under the
helper function which is called check
datalog check dataloader just iterates
one time over the whole data set
to see if it works
and
we have four subtests here one for each
split and one for single and multiple
workers
okay what have we learned so far for
data sets it's important to think about
testing each split if we have multiple
splits please think about what are the
differences in behavior and
what do i expect from each split second
test as few samples as possible
if you know something about your data
set for example that it's
all the same image size you only have to
test one sample for other
use cases you may have to test
more data even the whole data set
sometimes is prohibitive but
yeah
try to minimize the compute power you
need here because this is the most
data intensive part of the unit tests
and third stick to public interfaces if
you've paid attention you may have
noticed that i did not call any other
methods on
our data set then the get item method
with
the brackets
this is because
the unit tests should only test your the
public interface of of whatever you're
testing
otherwise
when your internals change your tests
have to change too so this
kind of test could be
reused over and over again for each data
set because
the data set api is fixed in python i
don't know when was the last time it
changed
i think in 11 it changed [ __ ] um
yeah it changed recently but before that
it didn't change
yeah
when you start testing the internals
some private functions of your data set
when you
maybe delete this private function
because you don't know it or you want to
split the function even further you have
to change your unit tests again and this
is just a lot of overhead you're
producing here so stick to public
interfaces if you can
okay next one
testing your model
i talked about public interfaces this is
the most reusable part of this talk
because the public interface for pi
dodge models is
pretty fixed
this time really
so the first time first thing we want to
test is what was in our intro we want to
see if the output shape
of
our
model is the right one given a specific
input
so here we instantiate our
variation outer encoder it's it expects
an input shape
and because it's an auto encoder it
should
output a tensor of exactly the same
shape so what we do is random input put
it through our net and see if the shape
matches
pretty easy the thing to notice here is
the decorator above the function
this is the torch no great decorator
which just disables the gradient
accumulation for pytorch we don't need
this for
for this
test
and
it just makes it much faster because
then
pytorch is just disabling all the tape
stuff in the background and runs it
just with a forward pass
as i said keep the computational
overhead for your test slow and this is
one thing you should do for all your
model stuff
we didn't have to do it for the other um
for the data set stuff because we didn't
have any tensors that require the
gradient there but here we have the the
weights of our model which require a
gradient so pie torch would start
accumulating them
okay
next thing is moving to devices
so most of you probably want to train on
a gpu
and the most basic thing to do here is
just call model pong
dot cuda
and be done with it
this can fail actually
um
so here is
one function of our
variation auto encoder the bottleneck
function
and who of you can see
the problem here when moving this to the
gpu
actually it's
the first line of the function where we
generate the noise tensor because when
we are working on the gpu
um the mu and the log sigma tensors will
be on the gpu but
by default torch instantiates all the
tensors on the cpu which it will do with
rand here so the noise tensor will be on
the cpu but the other tensors will be on
the gpu and when then when you try to
multiply them it will fail
so
the fix is quite um quick we just call
rent like
and this is done
but again
if you test only on your laptop maybe it
doesn't has a gpu and
you then deploy it into production and
it fails
this is not good so you should test it
beforehand
and the test is pretty simple
first we instantiate the model then we
move it to the gpu then we move it back
this gives us three copies of our model
the first one
on the cpu the second one on the gpu and
a third one that is back on the cpu and
then we just
pipe a random input through it
and see if all the inputs outputs are
the same
again we have the torch no great
decorator here which helps us because we
don't need gradients and makes it faster
and the second decorator here is
a little cautionary step because as i
said maybe the machine you're running on
doesn't have a gpu
and then this test will fail
but you don't want to tel the test
to fail because of some external
configuration thingy so this test is
skipped by the test runner unless uh
torch knows that
a gpu is available otherwise it will
just say a test was skipped because no
gpu was detected
yeah this is um extremely important if
you later want to do something like a ci
where you may not have
a cpu which will just fail
directly if you don't wrap it in this
decorator
okay the second thing you should notice
here is that before each call to the
network we set a manual seat a manual
random seat for a torch
this is because our network is the
probabilistic model
and
it is non-deterministic because of this
noise tensor that i have shown before so
we just set the manual seat here
to a nice value each time before we
evaluate to make sure that the
output of our networks can be the same
otherwise it will just fail
um but
the random seed of torch is not the only
one you should be aware of
the other one
is
the one of numpy and the python random
seed so this is a little hepa function
that i've wrote for my tests it's just
called make deterministic and first of
all it sets the manual uh seat in pi
torch
then it sets the qdnn backend to
deterministic because otherwise qdn
will try to
find the best algorithm for your stuff
and this
may lead to problems later on it says
number random seed and the
python random seed too
okay i have to speed up a bit here next
thing is sample independence which is
basically if you put a batch of
samples through your network
these samples should not interfere with
each other on the backward pass
otherwise your model may do something
stupid
so each of these batch each of these
samples in the batch should produce the
same output if they're in the batch or
if they're just piped through
on their own to do that we are just
going to do a small backward past and we
are going to mask the loss for one of
our samples and then check if the
gradient is zero for the mask one and if
there are non-zero for all the other
ones
what you should see here is that we do
not have the no gradient
decorator because this time we need the
gradients and the other thing is that we
put our network into evil mode because
there's one interaction between the
batch stuff in the training mode and
this is the running mean of our batch
norm
so
be aware of that there can be
interactions between the samples in your
model
that you want and for this test to
succeed you have to deactivate them
okay next thing is parameter updates
which is all the parameters in your
network should be updated when you do an
optimization step if they are not this
is weird because then the parameters are
either not used
or
you did something wrong
which is basically just again do a
backward pass do an optimizer step and
see if the gradients are there so if
they are not one none and if there is
if the gradient norm is bigger then is
greater than zero which they should be
in this case because we did a really
dumb loss
okay these four tests are
the same for each model in my opinion so
every model you do you will need these
four tests so you should reuse them but
you are you should not just copy the
code what you should do is
do a test template to do that in
the unit test framework you just move
some of the code that you're using in
all of your unit tests namely defining
an input and defining the network to the
setup method this method is
automatically called before each of your
test functions
and what you then do is just lift the
setup method up to to a template class
where you just define all of your unit
tests and then have child classes for
each of your different models that uh
inherit from this template class and you
if you are then adding a new model for
example this cnn variation out encoder
here you just have to instantiate a new
child class and then you have all the
tests that you already have for your for
your previous model low overhead
the last thing you should do test your
trainer
first of all you should test your losses
this is a kl divergence loss
which is used in the variational
autoencoder
normally i would have asked if anyone
sees the error of the joke is that there
is no error but
nobody would have guessed that
but still every time i call this down
i make an error and i just
get it afterwards what you should do in
these cases is try to find an
implementation of this function or this
loss in some other package luckily scipy
has a kl divergence function that we can
use here to test if our version which
can produce gradients
um
is the same so what we do here is we
generate two distributions take samples
from them put them in the scipy kl
divergence function and see if the
output of this gold standard function is
the same as an our function
which is this in this case
be aware you're comparing floats here so
even though they should be the same they
most of the time are not so we add a
little delta here so the um difference
there can be a difference between them
but they should be in the same ballpark
okay
next thing logging because uh when
you're training the seats and you didn't
lock anything you don't know if it did
test the logging i have to speed up
again
so
this is pretty straightforward
one thing you should
keep in mind use the mock package look
it up because i don't have any more time
next thing this is
a really simple test but it's really
important check if your
whole setup is able to overfit on a
single batch
if it is it's
most probable that it will able to
be able to fit your whole data set yeah
so what this does is it just trains on a
single batch for a long time and sees if
the loss is
really small
okay
next thing
um
skip that next thing
um when should you run the tests all the
time
but you will forget it i forget it all
the time and then you have outdated
tests and buggy code so what you should
do is
uh use continuous integration you will
say okay continuous integration is hard
to set up it's not
github actions makes it easy this is the
code you use you just put it in your
repository github action stores all the
other stuff it works
if you want to see this talk again
because i was just too quick
you can check out my blog this talk is
there as an article
and some other stuff
and then thank you for your time
[Applause]
yeah thanks timon
for the quite
getting more and more fast talk
[Laughter]
and with a lot of information um i think
we
are interesting guys we'll go more into
detail and look into your blog post
we have also some
questions
i have to
okay um
two questions
maybe we can also find several questions
here in the audience but you start with
the two questions how fast
is a test that needs to go over the
whole data set like the one you showed
with the scaling
is this manageable with huge data sets
no
okay obviously if your data set is big
you don't want to do that um
here you have a trade-off between
precision and speed so you could just
sample a smaller version of your data
set and go over that and live with the
probability that there is an error but
as we've seen in previous talks there
are also these data
unit tests which can help with this
problem just
move
stuff like this where you
like want to see if your data is even
worth anything your data quality to
another step in your pipeline
okay and then we have a second question
oh the first was from lucia and the
second one is from martin
where do you store test data
if it's too big for storing
it in the same git repository as
so it in the same git repository as a
code
i don't understand the question i have
to think i think the question is
and let's answer it that way you should
not commit your test your data yes
so
what
this
example does it just uses
the torch vision version of mnist and
downloads it when the test runs for the
first time
so for a small data set you can do that
please do not commit them otherwise you
should have like a hosted version of it
maybe an s3 bucket or something like
that where your tests can download it
um
otherwise sometimes it's
maybe okay to like if you have an image
data set and you have one single image
that you can try some stuff on you can
commit that but please do not commit
code to your github repository it will
just be too big
code is okay you said code
data
code is okay data is not
sorry
okay um
several questions in the audience to the
talk
hopefully
for some other question
no so but we are also done now with the
time actually so thanks again tillman
[Applause]